hello everyone I hope you'll enjoyed my
yesterday's video if on trips bald King
March against ye but it's time to get
back to our 1991 Lin are a series
featuring also vastly von Schuch
this is round eight he has the black
pieces against Vishwanathan Anand in the
previous seven games event truck won two
games and drew five but the games he won
were against the world number one and
world champion garry kasparov rated 2800
that's simply an amazing rating for 1991
and the second game he won was against
world number two and former world
champion anatoly karpov so he won took
one against one number one in world
number two and he drew five more games
this is round eight and Anand plays
efore c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 d6 d4 C capture some before Knight
captures neither Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 and a6 Avant who goes for the night
off variation Bishop to c5 c4 e6
transposing into the Shiva ningún
variation on castles we have Bishop to
e7 Bishop to b3 event took castles f4
and now b5 Allen goes for f5 and b4
Knight to a4 and Kenny one should
capture this pawn on e4 well no he can't
if he would capture there's simply too
much pressure on e6f captures on e6 you
can't really recapture this what is
threatening to capture on f6 and for
example Knight goes back to f6 now
capturing on f7 with check King h8 and
now Bishop to e6 this is just terrible
for black so after Knight to a4 he went
to plate 'if I've now kicking that night
away from d4 we have nice to eat too and
well can the pawn be captured now
unfortunately not because if Knight
captures only for Queen to d5 now with
an attack on this night and also with an
attack on the rook so this would also be
very unfortunate
so after Knight to e2 event you played
Bishop to b7 and now he definitely is
threatening to capture the pawn
so on on the defense it nice to g3 and
we have Knight B to d7 preparing to jump
to c5 to add more pressure to the e4
pawn and also to guard this b6 square if
Anand develops the bishop for example on
e3 king queen to e1 adding more
protection to the pawn and now a5 we
have c4 Queen to c7 Queen to e2 rook F
the c8 Bishop to g5 night
the c5 now adding one more attacker to
the e4 pawn and Anand plays rook a to C
1 and this is also a very interesting
position Avant show is now attacking the
e4 pawn three times
so can the pawn be captured now well not
really
if knife captures then Knight captures
and after Knight captures then
commission captures on e7 Queen captures
on e7 and now Knight to b6 forking the
rooks and well this was definitely a
favor white so I have two rook a to C
one event took place h6 saying to Anna
and the well either capture my knight on
f6 and I will then have the bishop pair
or remove your Bishop from g5 and of
course doesn't want to give me vine to
the bishop pair he plays the Bishop to
d3 which is which is a good move it
threatens this night on c5 and also if
the knight moves this night can freely
jump to b6 as now this Bishop on e3 is
protecting b6 event replace night C to
b7 now this Knight is guarding the b6
square and we have Bishop to F to rook
to a 6 by vine choke adding more
protection to the b6 square but also
with an idea of now free in this a 8
square for the Queen for example Queen
b8 Queen a 8 so adding more pretty more
more attack to the e4 pawn that way
rook the c2 by Anand we have Queen to b8
now proceeding with the plan a rook to
e1 now over protecting the e4 pawn
quint we ate it's now adding more
pressure to the a4 pawn and Queen to d3
so now that the rook is defending the
pawn before the Queen and well there's
really no way to add any more pressure
to the four point immediately but you
magic finds a different idea he plays
Knight to g4 and this is this is a
beautiful square for the knight because
he wants to improve the position of this
Knight and e7 now we want to freed this
f6 Square for this other night and what
like I said this Knight is excellent on
g4 you know you can't really kick it
away from there it's also threatening
this beautiful bishop this opponent's
Bishop on f2 it is a monster piece look
at this diagonal it's slicing and
playing h3 event you will simply capture
the bishop and you'll simply weaken your
your Kings protection so we have 92 f1
Reema nuvaring the knight - D - to
protect e4 from there we have the other
knife comes to f6 now adding more
pressure to d4 pawn and now Knight the
d2 adding more defense to the e4 pawn so
well this entire game is basically about
this efore pawn knife captures an F -
now vastly eliminates this immensely is
the powerful piece that is the bishop on
f2 King captures an f2 and Bishop the c6
and to understand this Bishop to c6 move
you really have to you really have to
see far far into the future like
eventual does as you'll see later rook
c2 c1 by Anand we have Queen to a7 with
check King goes to e to rock to d8
Bishop to d1 and now well what is every
player is a dream I mean every player
who plays the Sicilian dreams of one
thing and that is to push d5 in the
Sicilian and even finds a way to do it
here he plays d5 see characters on d5
and now Knight captures on d5 a bunch of
sacrifices denied he capture sandy
five and rook capture 75 would an attack
on the Queen and well this is a very
unpleasant position for Anand as you as
you see this queen is slicing all the
way this way the rook is attacking the
Queen the bishop is well after the rook
moves it will be guarding f3 so this
King it's really stuck there on e2 this
is very unpleasant here aren't played
Queen to b3 and well one of the reasons
eventual might have played Bishop to c6
could be explained with the idea that in
this position you want to catch the
immediate win with rook captures on B to
check and this is a forcing variation
King character son B - Queen - f - check
rook three - defending now Bishop to g5
with check King to c2 now Queen captures
on f5 would check you have to block this
check Queen to d3 and now Bishop
captures on a4 and well this could have
been why event you played a bishop to c6
in that position but it's really not
b3 now rook the c6 check King has to go
back and now Bishop captures on c1 with
check King to a-1 and Queen captures on
d3 white is completely lost he's getting
checkmated in three moves and well this
like I said it's a forcing variation in
seven moves but this is not what event
you played after Queen to b3 event you
did not capture the knight on D - rather
he calmly improves the position with
Bishop to g5 now threatening to capture
on D - so that that the White King can't
even recapture it on and here plays rook
to c2 now defending this night and even
took plays Bishop captures on b2 and in
this possession position on and resigned
the game what's the idea here well the
idea is that after rook captures on d2
avanti has this Bishop to b5 check and I
believe this move is the reason why that
Bishop to c6 was played this is the
position even Chuck saw when he played
Bishop to c6 rook has the block rough to
d3 and now
captures on d3 and it's game over for
Anand Anand is losing the Queen and if
he tries to protect the Queen for
example with a move like Queen to c2
this leads the checkmate Queen to e3
check King to f1 rook captures on d1
King the Queen has to lock the check
from the bishop on b5 and I'll simply
Bishop captures on me - with checkmate
and a look at this beautiful
constellation but none of this none of
this happened after Bishop captures on
d2 on and saw that this is completely
winning for even shook and he resigned
the game so so far
he won took one against the Garry
Kasparov Anatoly Karpov and Vishwanathan
Anand now this was around 8 and well
we'll just continue with this beautiful
tournament that is Linares 1991 so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Arturo Cardenas
and the Jason Pierce Sweeney for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here they will be about even
choke sir
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon